[Music]
she eventually got her big bang but she
had to wear a fat suit first and that
was just one step on kaylee cuoco's
journey
kaylee cuoco grew up in camarillo
california which is only an hour away
from los angeles this made kaylie's
early dreams of being a child actor
easier to pursue but her desire to act
came with a deal from her parents she
had to have a back-up plan this led to
kaylee developing many hobbies as a
child aside from acting there was of
course modeling and tennis as a child
but as an adult she has maintained very
eclectic tastes outside of her usual job
including equestrianism and drumming
however it didn't take her long to get
started with her plan a career as she
began landing commercials when she was
about five years old her television
debut came in 1992 when she was cast as
connie reinhardt in the made for tv
movie quicksand no escape from there
cuoco's career was set in motion and she
began landing roles on some of the
decade's most popular shows popping up
in 1994 in episodes of northern exposure
and my so-called life two years later
she was on abc's ellen playing a young
version of ellen degeneres's character
like many child actors kaylie's
increased opportunities eventually led
her to the disney channel throughout her
youth she appeared in numerous disney
productions starting with the tv film
toothless starring kirstie alley as a
dentist turned tooth fairy however one
of her more recognizable roles as a
teenager came with the disney channel
original movie ally cats strike which
was released in 2000 and allowed cuoco
to show off her bowling skills i think
you're doing better soon you learn you'd
have to throw the ball so hard it took
me a long time to learn that
not only was this a big opportunity for
the up-and-coming actor but it ended up
being a pivotal moment in her youth
according to an interview with w
magazine this role led to kaylee's first
kiss though it wasn't on screen she went
on a date with an actor from the movie
who ended up being fired her work with
disney continued from 2004 to 2006 as
she voiced brandy on the animated series
brandy and mr whiskers and lent her
voice talents to the bratz franchise as
kirstie
by the time she was a teenager cuoco was
a nationally ranked tennis player even
though she gave up the sport to pursue
her acting career she decided to
continue her other hobby of riding
horses as she told the new zealand
herald i have six horses and they have
been the biggest blessing in my life
horseback riding is why i'm so centered
especially in this business i wouldn't
have my career without it the next
decade brought even more opportunities
cuoco played maureen mccormick in the tv
movie growing up brady in 2000 that same
year she scored a recurring role on the
cbs sitcom ladies man coming on as
bonnie styles for season two
kaylee cuoco's big break almost didn't
happen thanks to a bad audition however
producers could see she was right for
the show and called her agent asking if
she would try again that's why in 2002
she was cast as bridget on abc's eight
simple rules she played the oldest child
in the hennessey family a beautiful
ditzy blonde preoccupied with boy drama
she embraced the role telling sidewalks
so i did end up getting the job which
totally changed the course truly of
actually my life and my career it kind
of put me on the map and made me realize
how much i love sitcoms when her
on-screen father john ritter died
suddenly in 2003 cuoco was heartbroken
and the show faced an unexpected
challenge new characters were introduced
and portrayed by actors trying to fill
ritter's role eight simple rules was
able to continue until 2005 but cuoco
would never forget the man so near and
dear to her heart to this day if anyone
asks me john ritter i i get this chill
because i love him
so much
in 2005 kaylee cuoco was offered a role
on the wb's charmed in its eighth season
she was initially nervous to come on as
billy jenkins a new witch among a
star-studded cast but she felt at home
after a warm welcome from alyssa milano
she told yahoo entertainment i know what
it's like when someone new comes on
there's people like alyssa who really do
mould your career and mould your path so
that was a really good moment cuoco
appeared in 22 episodes throughout the
final season and viewers hoped she might
get a spin-off series that was not to be
but fans would see her again on screen
soon enough
for one of her roles in the mid-2000s
kaylee was cast in the lifetime movie to
be fat like me in it she plays a high
school athlete who dons a fat suit in a
social experiment to see how differently
overweight people are treated by society
the film's reviews played out exactly as
you'd think they would for a lifetime
movie but cuoco's performance was
praised despite this film's blatantly
obvious message it's a decent showcase
of cuoco's skill as a dramatic actor of
course the biggest break in her career
saw her sticking to her comedy chops
when she first auditioned for the big
bang theory she didn't get the part of
penny in fact the role didn't even exist
early on cuoco tried out for a different
version of the character a girl named
katie but at 19 years old she was too
young for the part after filming the
first pilot producers decided to make
some changes that's when they created
penny brought cuoco back and cast her in
the role as she told entertainment
tonight i came in i got the job and it
got picked up and it was like this
whirlwind it was awesome penny started
off as a bubbly pretty girl next door
type but over the course of 12 seasons
on the show cuoco had the chance to put
her skills to work and ran with it she
created an edgier character with more
depth who played a major role in the
sitcom's success
kaylee's time on the big bang theory was
certainly a career highlight but it was
ultimately a stepping stone to her true
dream in 2012 kaylee organized a flash
mob featuring the casting crew on the
set of the big bang theory surprising
the audience and producers with a dance
routine with choreography helped by
kaylee's sister brianna after a video of
the flash mob went viral kaylee talked
about it at a paley center panel
it's just been a dream of mine
mom and i said guess what you're all
doing it with me
thankfully they got to do it again in
2014 and then once more during the
shooting of the final season
the success of the big bang theory soon
made kaylee cuoco a recognizable face in
the world of television comedy it wasn't
long until that face began appearing on
magazines in commercials and elsewhere
in hollywood cuoco also landed some
prestigious hosting gigs in 2011 she
hosted the teen choice awards as well as
the people's choice awards in 2012 and
2013. she wasn't just hosting award
shows either as she won emmys in 2014
and 2015. kaylee cuoco's tv stardom
doesn't end there she also made a splash
joining william shatner for a series of
priceline.com commercials cuoco played
shatner's character's daughter and she's
continued to promote priceline.com as
recently as 2022 she's also since done
tv spots for toyota and smirnoff vodka
the 2010 saw kaylee cuoco's career
expand beyond her beloved cbs sitcom in
2011 she spent her big bang hiatus
appearing alongside james marsden in the
easter themed family comedy hop the
movie found kaylee acting opposite a
computer animated character for the
first time but she also landed other
roles in much more adult comedies with
actual adults in 2014 she executive
produced and starred in authors
anonymous where she played a writer
whose overnight success results in the
ire of her former weekly writers group
she also played a supporting role in the
wedding ringer alongside kevin hart and
josh gad which received mostly negative
reviews from critics however she and gad
later reunited to compete against each
other in an episode of lip sync battle
in 2015 kaylee also starred in the
independent film burning bodhi about a
group of friends who reunite after one
of them passes away along with her
supporting role in 2011's the last ride
a biopic of country legend hank williams
this marked kaylie's first official
foray into dramatic film
the longer the big bang theory went on
the more its cast became sitcom royalty
it also became important that the show
didn't suffer a loss of actors which is
known to happen when sitcoms continue
for years this meant that over the
course of 12 seasons many of the show's
biggest stars received tremendous pay
raises in the first season the main trio
of cuoco johnny galecki and jim parsons
each earned 60 thousand dollars as their
salary for the entire season while the
other main cast members netted 45
thousand dollars cuoco and her cast
mates negotiated for higher payment in
2010 resulting in each actor gaining two
hundred thousand dollars per episode by
the last season cuoco galecki parsons
simon hellberg and kunal nayer were each
getting 1 million dollars per episode
making them one of the highest paid
casts in sitcom history post the big
bang theory cuoco's fortune has allowed
her to play a bigger role in executive
producing projects like harley quinn and
the flight attendant
in october 2017 kaylee cuoco founded her
own production company yes norman
productions entering a multi-year deal
with warner brothers to develop projects
together the first of these new
endeavors was an adaptation of the
crispo jallian novel the flight
attendant this limited series stars
cuoco as cassie bowden a flight
attendant who sleeps with the passenger
only to wake up to find his dead body in
bed with her the flight attendant
premiered on hbo max in november 2020
despite the show being originally
ordered as a limited series its success
led to hbo picking it up for a second
season which premiered in 2022 cuoco's
partnership with warner's continued in
2019 with the premiere of harley quinn
an adult animated series starring cuoco
as the titular villain
you're lucky i even showed up oh was
batman too busy doing this i'd
definitely make love two bats shut up
and battle me nars oh god
in summer 2018 variety reported that
series creator chuck laurie called the
cast into his office where jim parsons
announced the upcoming 12th season of
the big bang theory would be his last
sticking with lori's plan not to
continue without any of its main cast
members the show prepared to reach its
finale cuoco maybe more than the rest of
the cast was in shock at parson's
decision feeling as if she could have
continued on in may 2019 the cast and
crew gathered one last time in front of
a studio audience to shoot the series
finale in the final episode penny is
revealed to be pregnant which many fans
and critics felt was a betrayal of her
character arc what if what if we didn't
have kids
ever
i mean our life is so great why would we
want to change that unfortunately for
big bang fans hoping for a reunion
episode cuoco has no desire to have a
do-over on the series feeling satisfied
with how it ended in an interview on the
one show she claimed she'll never be
able to compare anything she does in the
future to her experience on the show
having a successful sitcom doesn't
guarantee success later in your career
as cuoco learned even after auditioning
for ryan johnson's sequel to knives out
she found out that she ultimately wasn't
cast in a cover story for glamour
magazine kaylee discussed how she was
convinced she had a part in the film but
the part instead went to kate hudson she
admitted that her bags were already
packed to head to greece where the movie
was shot but she didn't stay down for
long she was offered a role in meet cute
shortly after a romantic comedy she
ended up filming with pete davidson
[Music]